we had a great response to the
statistics challenge or the last
challenge that we put out there so now
we're throwing out another challenge and
this one deals with cosmology and the
video at the scratchpad goes into more
depth but it's all about whether we can
model accretion disks accretion disks or
this phenomenon that we see over and
over again in cosmology whether we're
talking about the matter that's
accreting around a black hole or the Y
galaxies often have a flat disk shape or
why all of the planets in our solar
system seem to be along the same plane
because when the solar system was
forming from this cloud of matter an
accretion disk formed that was this that
was all along this one this one plane
and so the goal of this and once again
this goes into much more depth is to see
using our scratch pad whether folks can
create a simulation start with the cloud
of matter and through gravitational
interactions and maybe some random
initial velocities that clouds of matter
in three dimensions actually don't just
compress but they actually start to
rotate and that they actually will form
an accretion disk and the star here has
nothing to do with the project it's just
they're just so we have a nice little
icon for this thing so i encourage you
to delete this code when you start to
work on it and then create a
mind-blowing simulation that shows us
how accretion disk form and as you might
have already noticed obviously whoever
creates awesome simulations we will give
credit to them we think this is a fun
project just to work on but we also hope
to use this in the Khan Academy at
minimum the cosmology playlist but maybe
the physics playlist and maybe other
places because the one thing we realize
is that the community is really really
really good at coming up with really
really really neat ways to visualize and
simulate things so I'll thank you ahead
of time and good luck